el sismo sorprendió a los habitantes en
plena noche
aquí en Villar vaquir la gran ciudad del
sureste de Turquía esto es todo lo que
quedó de un edificio de varias plantas
estos residentes intentaron retirar los
escombros mientras esperaban la llegada
de ayuda
un poco más tarde los primeros cadáveres
Fueron extraídos por los socorristas aún
trabajando de madrugada mientras los
habitantes lidian con lo que acaba de
ocurrir
el terremoto fue muy violento muy
aterrador había mucho ruido por todas
partes los temblores tardaron casi dos
minutos en detenerse
eran alrededor de las 4:17 cuando la
tierra tembló cerca de la ciudad de
garzantiapa 7,8 de magnitud en la escala
de richter y muy largo como muestra este
video aficionado grabado al interior de
una vivienda
ocho provincias del sureste se vieron
afectadas las autoridades han decretado
una alarma a nivel 4 y piden ayuda a la
comunidad internacional
todos los gobernadores están trabajando
actualmente los gendarmes las fuerzas
del orden las fuerzas armadas turcas La
media luna roja todos nuestros equipos
de rescate y búsqueda se han desplegado
en las distintas zonas afectadas
el también golpeó con fuerza la vecina
Siria allí muchos edificios sin
cimientos sólidos o dañados por la
guerra se derrumbaron como muestran
estas imágenes
cientos de personas han muerto en todo
el país con la ayuda de los residentes
locales los bomberos y los trabajadores
de Protección Civil están trabajando
para encontrar sobrevivientes
del otro lado de la frontera en Turquía
también hay cientos de víctimas y miles
de heridos